foreign
let's go to Julie and Saint Paul
Minnesota hi Julie welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi thanks for taking my call sure
um I've had recently my husband and I
have had some changes with work and what
I'm trying to figure out is how to make
um monthly contributions that we both
make to a joint household account
Equitable and fair
um he's recently accepted a new job
making considerably more money
um and I'm straight commission so my
money is always variable
it'd be different if you know we had he
made a hundred thousand imh 50 then it's
pretty easy how to figure out but how do
you figure something out when somebody's
variable commission every month how long
have you guys been married
we've been married about three years
we've been together about eight and
sharing finances for about six okay well
my answer is really simple Julie it's
all of yours together
so once it hits a bank account that you
guys share regardless of who brings in
the money it is your money you guys
together as a couple
it is your both of your money both of
your monies all of your monies together
so
um you're acting like you're still
roommates you're not roommates your
husband and wife
and so there's a there's a power teacher
said and now you are one he did not
pronounce you a joint venture
there is okay there is power and Power
in combining finances combining checking
accounts working out of the same pot
regardless of who brings in the money
that together you're a team and and even
studies recently there's been like two
or three recently coming out talking
about even the satisfaction the marriage
satisfaction and joy is higher with
couples that see themselves as one when
it comes to money and it is it's
probably one of the more
counter-cultural things I feel like we
talk a lot about countercultural stuff
on the show but for so many people they
do what you guys do they're running
these kind of these two separate Lanes
trying to figure out okay who pays what
Bill what's fair what's equal
when you just scrap all of that and say
hey this is our house when our incomes
come in it is our income what are we
going to do with our money and you see
yourself as a team as one as Unified
and and my thing is I'm like if you can
share a bed
you can share a bank account you guys
are married you are one you are together
now in your budget you have a line item
that's a Julie line item and you have
money to go and spend and enjoy and
that's great you know I have a Rachel
line item
and I can go buy a sweaters and new pair
of jeans and I'm not having to like text
him every time right we have a certain
amount of money that I get to spend
every month a certain amount of money he
spends so there's still a level of yeah
you still you have money to spend but
that's agreed upon that amount together
and so something changes Julie I'm
telling you you both have power not just
tactically things change when you
combine accounts but emotionally the
unity that's created you start to see
yourselves as one and you win faster
financially when you do that you work
together you communicate there's so
there's so many Pros I'm telling you so
many Pros that come out so much data to
back this up by the way of working
together it's it it sounds devastatingly
old-fashioned though doesn't it
a little bit yeah when you've been very
independent
attributed equally too you know but that
always sometimes but it kind of the
problem is when you're doing it your way
it almost feels like if you're not
putting in more your vote doesn't count
as much
and it does you have equal votes in the
marriage and equal votes on whether we
buy a house equal votes on whatever's if
you don't believe me visit divorce court
they'll give both of you an equal vote
right the law says that exactly the law
says that so here's an interesting
extreme okay my wife Sharon left the
workplace uh of her own choice uh when
my oldest daughter Rachel's older sister
was born and Denise is what 30 something
years old right so for 30 something
years Sharon has not had an income
and yet Sharon has a great income
because we have a great income
we own a house now we do at our house
still say that's your car because it's
the one she drives more than me and it's
the one with a dent from hitting the
garage door but I said that out loud but
yeah that's your car this is my car but
they're our cars it's our vacation it's
our retirement it's our money and we are
going to design a life we want to live
together we both have a vote she has the
same vote I have and she brings nothing
of income to the equation
I didn't say she brought nothing to the
equation I said she brought nothing of
income to the equation let's be very
very clear about that after the garage
door joke but um I'm already in deep
kimchi here but the uh but that that's
the uh uh that's the thing so yeah I I
think um
I I think that uh uh I think you can try
this
as an experiment because there's nothing
that says you can't undo our suggestion
try it for six months Julie between now
and summer
change your language
when you do
our
not yours and mine our
our and see if you don't notice some
subtle shifts with that communication in
your relationship
it's it's proven and it's just we've
been doing this a long time and we
Rachel's right we get trashed on social
media for this because it's like it's so
it's it's like old-fashioned see the old
marriage vows you know uh for richer for
poorer we've all heard that in sickness
and health we all heard that the old
book of common prayer marriage vows say
unto thee all my worldly Goods I pledge
that's you don't hear that in a weren't
marriage anymore either no but in you
know 50 years ago almost every wedding
you went to you would have heard that
okay and our 60 years ago
um I've been married 40 and it wasn't in
mine but um
but yeah I mean that's it's old school
is what I'm saying it's kind of it's got
a very uh uh almost a Victorian feel to
it now and what can come with that is
the sense that you've lost power and
we're not suggesting that your vote is
diminished no I'll guaran dad blame to
you to you my uh hillbilly wife has a
vote okay she takes her she'll call you
a hillbilly can you call her a hillbilly
she's hillbilly too we're both noble
noble Hillbillies but uh but I mean the
chances of me taking away your mother's
vote is zero right oh my God even if I
wanted to be overbearing it's not an
option okay yeah that 100 100 and I will
say this one of the pushbacks I get on
social media is well
and now we have separate accounts and we
don't fight anymore it's because you're
just denial that's okay so that's my
point is I'm like that's the exact fight
you need need to be having to have a
deep rich marriage like you can't just
sweep things under the rug and function
like two different you know two
different places and then call that okay
that's not okay I woke up and didn't
admit it it changed it forces you to
communicate and and work together as a
team and I'm telling you Julie it's
worth it it changes in your marriage
that's our pitch give it a shot